[Music]
if I go back to that time outs are
shaking and sweating you get all nervous
and my heart will pound I might not give
the whole let me tell you what I would
focus on i would say it as we all know
hear that what we have created is unique
and it's solving a gigantic problem no
one in unearthed is gonna do we've done
and when you use this product we all
know how magical it is it will find its
home everybody in the planet loves music
there are millions of musicians that
produce great music and they can't find
each other when this thing finally finds
its home it's going to change culture
and how many times in your life to get a
chance to do that that's what this is
about they work
[Music]